this is probably not the ben shapiro
show audience but you know my
progressive friends will want me to
acknowledge
that some bad things happened uh across
the the settling of the west and and all
that kind of stuff
uh but you know it was done for a reason
and i'm basically arguing for a
continuation
of that kind of vision that you know the
united states
is great and should want to be great and
powerful and that that means
having more people amidst the growing
outrage mobs and the increasing
frequency of individuals being cancelled
we feed in the internet trolls and
reward them i'm not gonna do it man
harper's magazine published a letter on
justice and open debate in july of this
year
signed by thought leaders cultural
figures and writers the letter
criticizes the strict orthodoxy of the
left
stating quote the free exchange of
information and ideas the lifeblood of a
liberal society is daily becoming more
constricted
and adding quote we need to preserve the
possibility of good faith disagreement
without dire professional consequences
many outspoken progressives signed on to
the letter including jk rowling stephen
pinker noam chomsky gloria steinem and
one matthew iglesias
iglesias one of the co-founders of vox
and host of vox's podcast the weeds
ended up being called out by his own
company on cue for his participation
critic at large for box emily
vanderworth accused matt of supporting
anti-trans dog whistles because the
letter closely followed outrage about jk
rowling's stance that trans women are
not the same as biological women
fellow vox co-founder ezra klein added
on twitter quote a lot of debates that
sell themselves as being about free
speech
are actually about power and there's a
lot of power in being able to claim
and hold the mantle of free speech
defender matt and other signatories to
the harper's letter speak to how far the
retribution has spread
today we'll get into where matt finds
himself in that controversy and where we
go from here in this age of intolerance
plus we get into matt's 2020 election
thoughts and his new book
one billion americans in which matt
makes the argument that the u.s
population needs to get a whole lot
bigger
if we're going to be the winners of the
future
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
sponsored by expressvpn your data is
your business protected at
expressvpn.com
then welcome to the ben shapiro show
sunday special today
we feature a very special guest matthew
iglesias just a reminder we'll be doing
some bonus questions at the end with
matt
and the only way to get access to that
part of the conversation is to go become
a member head on over to dailywire.com
become a member you'll have access to
all of the full conversations with every
one of our awesome and fascinating guest
matt thanks so much for joining the show
really appreciate it
oh thanks for having me so i'm really
eager to get into your book one billion
americans because it really is a lot of
content a lot of solutions some of which
obviously i'm going to agree with and
some of it some of which i
i disagree with but but before we get to
the book uh and again i want to get into
it in depth with you
um let's talk a little bit about the big
controversy of the last several months
that you were involved in
and that was this controversy
surrounding this harper's weekly letter
so
um you know i was a fan of the harper's
weekly letter obviously
i'm an opponent of what has been termed
cancel culture
you got some blow back on it um i kind
of want to start by asking you
what you perceive to be the definition
of cancelled culture because this has
obviously become extremely contentious
yeah i mean that's not really a word
that i use it's not a term that appears
in that letter i think it's a little bit
confused and people start sort of
arguing about terminology
um you know when i certainly see right
so
we're recording this it's on september
11th and i remember
you know in the months after that
happened some you know some
nice things happened to to america but
we also had you know
the house of representatives uh wanted
to change the name of french fries
uh we had the dixie chicks you know
people were smashing up their cds
because they didn't like something they
said about george w bush and more
recently you know we had
colin kaepernick sort of blacklisted
because people were angry about
his political statements so i kind of
reject the
construct that there's like a specific
left-wing phenomenon that we could call
cancel culture uh but i mean i do think
it's true that you know this happens in
all kinds of perspectives that people
lose it over you know somebody doing
something
that they disagree with politically
they'll say we gotta cut this person out
of our lives entirely
i can't watch you know a show anymore
because i don't like something the actor
said
and you know it's an unfortunate trend
so i i want to kind of dig in there a
little bit as to what actually
constitutes
a cancelling and what sort of activity
is appropriate and what what activity is
not so
yeah you mentioned a couple examples
some of which i agree with you sort of
constitute what people would term cancel
culture and some of which i probably
don't so you know not wanting to watch a
show because you don't like the politics
of it that seems to me like
okay so you turn off the show trying to
get somebody fired like for example if
you actually tried to blacklist colin
kaepernick and said he shouldn't be able
to play in the nfl despite his skill set
because of his perspective
that seems to be much more kind of in
line with cancel culture or somebody
doesn't like
your show or my show so they instead
decide that they're not going to turn
off our show which is perfectly fine
they decide instead they're going to go
after the advertisers on the show
because the advertisers are somehow
not trying to just reach the listeners
it's the advertiser's fault they've
somehow endorsed
the content of the particular show and i
kind of wanted to get your take on that
and and then i want to move and then i
want to also ask you about what do you
think the overton window should be
because we're i think we're both
discussing
uh you know content that's inside what
the overton window is
so i want to clarify that in a second
but first what do you think about that
definition of what counseling
constitutes
yeah i mean there's something to be said
for that i mean look obviously it's
difficult because i don't think you want
to say
you know nobody should ever go after
anyone's advertisers for anything right
like there's boundaries to decency and
polite society things like that uh to me
what's actually
most disturbing that people sometimes do
is the suggestion that there should be
this kind of
second degree shunning right so like
maybe ben shapiro
says some stuff that that i really
disagree with right it's really bad you
know because we talk about politics
these are important questions
uh so like don't go on his show right
and and like that to me
is not reasonable you know i mean i
in my book i cite a lot of people who i
have a lot of very serious disagreements
with
but i've learned important things from
them right and that we have points of
agreement and you know you want to have
an intellectual culture at least i want
to have an intellectual culture
in which people engage with each other
they argue respectfully they try to
change each other's minds
but also they just admit that like it's
fine in life to have points of agreement
and points of disagreement
and the disagreements are serious
they're about important things but
you know we don't need to drive people
out of public life
over disagreements or try to because
ultimately it doesn't work
right i mean in the internet age you
know you can't
stop people from having an audience like
on their podcast
on their youtube whatever you can try
right but it's it's ultimately futile
we're not in a world of three television
networks and
if you convince like two stakeholders
somebody's gonna be
like gone and shunned from the public
sphere so you know we might as well try
to
live with that reality most of the time
there's some stuff you know that's out
of bounds i mean i think that's sort of
common sense we
don't need to have i don't know like
nazis on cable or what have you but you
know
i think most reasonable people can
actually sort of agree on that and then
the problem becomes
in the application a specific case yeah
i mean i agree with that completely and
especially this is a funny conversation
because you and i have been probably
throwing slings and arrows at each other
for what 20 years online
and we can smile yeah it's been a long
time i mean since like
we we used to be young and you know
exactly now here we are and we're old
and we're still doing it but but
that reaches the question as to what
constitutes the overton window so i
think that we can agree on
you know the cases that are well outside
the overton window you mentioned you
know overt nazis
but one of the arguments now becomes
where does the
overton window shrink too much and this
is why i think you've seen people on the
right
look at the left and say you're
shrinking the overton window too much so
the harper's weekly letter
started off with all this content about
president trump you know some of which i
agree with some which i disagree with
but
the there was not a single person so far
as i could tell on that list who voted
for trump
i mean it's a list of probably 150
centered left
to to radical left including people like
noam chomsky intellectuals um but
there wasn't anybody who was probably uh
either a registered republican or a
trump voter
and i thought that actually weakened the
impact of a letter it seems like if
you're going to have a bipartisan
consensus that we shouldn't go around
excising people from public life that
the overton window has got to be a
little bit broader than mainstream
democratic party and left
yeah it's interesting i mean i wasn't
involved with right you know the
selection of who to be invited on it
george packer spoke to me um
it seemed like a reasonable letter i was
happy to sign on to it you know i think
maybe if i
i don't think i'm going to be organizing
any sign-on letters in the future but
you know if i
were to i might think about it a little
bit differently
uh from how they did that being said i
mean i think if you read that letter
right it's an intervention
into some arguments that are happening
inside progressive spaces and not really
about
things that are happening on the right
uh you know which is like a fine way to
put it
but you know also neutral principles are
important and you know
as i say like we've had i think it was
just you know a couple days ago
president trump was on tv saying like
this reporter and that reporter and that
reporter should all be fired
so you know it's
there's a lot of bad stuff happening in
the world
or at least elements of bad behavior you
know and i think that a
part of consensus of most of the people
who sign that letter most people on the
left whatever disagreements we have with
each other is that president trump has
been involved in some very disturbing
efforts to cr
clamp down on free speech i mean
including using real powers of the
presidency right there's been a lot of
suggestions
that he's trying to retaliate against
jeff bezos's
sort of personal business interests
because he doesn't like washington post
coverage
and that's a it's like a different it's
a different kind of thing from
you know people yelling at college
professors uh and
you know i think deserves to be treated
somewhat separately yeah i mean we can
get to president trump in a second i'm
sure
we'll get to president trump a fair bit
uh in the in the upcoming it's hard to
avoid talking about him these days yeah
he's the black hole of american politics
around all
which everything revolves we'll get to
that in just one second but first
let's talk about the fact that you do
need to protect your online data why
should you care about encrypting your
data well
it's often easy for a hacker to bypass
wi-fi security and steal your
information which is why i use
expressvpn to stay secure online
it's hard to know whether your device or
network is vulnerable and if you ever
use wi-fi at a hotel or shopping mall
any place public
you're sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption at all that's the
easiest place for hackers to steal that
information
the best way to ensure all of your data
is encrypted and can't be read by
hackers is to use expressvpn
just download the expressvpn app on your
computer or smartphone tap one button to
secure 100 of your network data and then
use the internet just the way you
normally would
expressvpn is incredibly reliable it's
the fastest vpn service
i've tried it is always a good idea to
protect yourself from the bad guys who
are looking for your information
make money off of you they take your
data and they monetize it it's your data
there is no reason why you would leave
it unprotected so if you want the best
in online security and privacy
protection head on over to
expressvpn.com
ben for three extra months free with a
one-year package protect your internet
today with the vpn i trust to keep my
own data safe go to expressvpn.com to
get started
so matt you you talk about president
trump there and sort of his treatment of
the press
i've decried when he has said that
members of the press are enemies of the
people i think it's ridiculous when he
suggests that reporters
ought to be fired for disagreeing with
him uh
i mean it also happens to be true that
president obama was not particularly
wonderful in regards to certain aspects
of the press i mean he attacked pretty
regularly fox news he also
uh sticked his justice department on the
associated press
uh they're they're they're unfortunately
this has become
as the executive power grows it seems
like there's become a bipartisan trend
of attempting to clamp down on people
with whom you disagree
in the cultural sphere it seems like
because the press maybe it's just
because the press tends to lean more
left there's a lot more push for
x has to be canceled because they
disagree with the left uh in the
cultural sphere although in the
governmental sphere obviously trump is
the president so he's the person from
the right doing it
right i mean look we have a lot of
polarization
along different demographic lines in
politics right so
young college graduates uh skew much
left of the overall population
and so in spaces where young college
graduates
are you know very numerous like in the
media or in
academic world you have a very sort of
left left-skewing debate
and the tendency is for people on the
right to want to appeal to sort of
neutral principles free speech etc
because they're the local minority there
in the electorate you know older people
working-class people actually punch
above their weight because of
the way the senate works because of
differential voter turnout
uh you know so in the political sphere
we have a very empowered
uh conservative movement at the moment
uh you know holding the presidency
and liberals are more likely to say oh
you know we we need to have freedom
appreciate the value of that you know
something i say
to college professors who are left-wing
you know particularly working at state
universities is
look like the median faculty member is
way to the left of the median state
legislator
and so they have an interest in mounting
a principled defense of academic freedom
and sort of
neutral speech principles and i think
the students don't always
appreciate that but it's important for
the faculty and the administrators to
you know i mean to not just like have
sound principles but to actually
understand how the game
works right ultimately which is that i
think progressives
benefit a lot from academic freedom in a
traditional sense
although also conservative professors do
i mean it's a good it's a good system
but i mean it's
it's genuinely worth fighting for yeah
matt one of the things that i appreciate
about what you're saying here is that
you know there there is this tendency on
i would say both sides of the aisle at
this point to move away from even the
concept of applicable neutral
principles uh the idea is on on the left
that free speech is actually just a
guise for for power politics uh in some
circles
that that you know things like you know
the the ability to speak
freely on a college campus well that's
only enshrining the power hierarchies
that are already implicit in the system
actually we saw a little bit of this
when you were criticized for signing
that letters from harper's weekly there
was a tweet actually from ezra
suggesting that some
of the criticisms of canceled culture
are coming from from power hierarchies
uh which you know i generally object to
that kind of language whether it comes
from the left or the right because you
see the right
some people on the the so-called common
good conservative right tend to do this
a little bit too
where they will suggest that neutral
principles are not being upheld by the
left therefore abandon the neutral
principle
and let's just duke this thing out that
seems to be incredibly dangerous and a
way for the country to basically break
if we can't agree that there are such
things as neutral principles that ought
to be applied neutrally
then it's hard to see how we're going to
stick together as a country
no i mean i think that's right i mean
you know neutrality is difficult and
people always disagree about it and
there's
something to the kind of hermeneutics of
suspicion
about these kind of things but i think
you know these ideals are worth
upholding and thinking about and and
trying to adhere to and you know you
were talking about
we're holding a large diverse country
together
right and that's like it's not it's
something i was thinking about a lot
actually when as i worked on this book
right which is you know what do we have
as a country right how can we think
about what we have in common
and you know what's valuable about
america what holds american people
together because you know there's plenty
that divides us we have plenty to
disagree about it's important to have
sort of political arguments amongst
ourselves that's the nature of democracy
but also like the united states has
succeeded in so far as it
has succeeded historically by having
some sense
also of togetherness we have a sort of
strong
civic nationalist tradition that you
know i think
gets eroded from both sides all the time
but also you know has pulled us together
historically and has been a real
strength of this country
so what do you think are those things
that hold us together so i i have a book
in which i posit that basically in order
for a nation to survive you have to have
at least a certain level of a common
version of american history you have to
have a certain level of adherence to a
common culture
you have to have a certain baseline
level of philosophy that you agree about
neutral principles for example like
freedom of speech or freedom of religion
um and that it seems like a lot of that
is is coming apart um
your approach is in in your book and
generally i think is much more
technocratic about like what we can do
together
uh in order to you know achieve certain
ends but i guess my question is more
about the ends because
it seems like right now we may in fact
be divided about the ends that we are
seeking to achieve not merely the means
for achieving those ends
yeah i mean it's possible i don't really
think that that's
true though fundamentally you know i
think when we look big picture right
like i think when you see things like
these concentration camps in xinjiang
for example like i think a really
broad swath not everybody in america but
a really broad swath of americans look
at that and they're like
you know like that's that's pretty bad
um or they look at you know the
crackdown on democracy in
in hong kong and they say oh that's
pretty bad or they look at something
like
an nba coach saying that crackdown is
bad
and then they see the league sort of
taking china's side
and we know why right though it's not
because
okay all those nba players are like
bought into chinese communist party
ideology
it's just money right there was an
incident a few years before that when
somebody in marketing for mercedes-benz
i don't know why they did this but they
like threw a quote from the dalai lama
on like an ad for a fancy car
and the chinese government freaked out
and the ceo of daimler
did this like groveling apology and
again i mean it would be interesting if
western societies were being like torn
apart
by uh chinese communist party ideology
but that's not what's
happening right it's just the market
power of china
has this kind of big growing influence
in the world
uh but i think all kinds of people
liberal people conservative people look
at that stuff
and you're like you know this is like
actually pretty troubling right
something we
actually agree on is that it would be
good for americans to be able to
you know make gestures of solidarity
with oppressed people in hong kong
without facing backlash from their
employers but there's a real question
like you know what do we do about that
or do we even do anything about it
because so far i mean i see all kinds of
like tutting from all sides of the world
but not
a lot of you know concrete action or
real ideas about how to handle these
challenges
so that does bring us to the topic of
your book one billion americans so
one of the things that that's really
interesting about about the book is that
it sort of backs a thesis that
nail ferguson has advanced that maybe
america
survives simply through opposition
meaning that you know maybe we were
better off during the cold war when
there was a ussr that provided a sort of
existential threat to the u.s where we
could look at the usr and say well you
know we may not like each other very
much but at least we're not those people
right at least we're not
living under soviet communism and yell
ferguson has pointed to china
as you just did and said that you know
americans may disagree about an awful
lot ranging from the state the status of
race relations to economics but one
thing that we're all pretty much agreed
on is that chinese communism and
imprisoning a million and a half
weaker muslims and and oppressing an
entire region in hong kong and
threatening taiwan like that stuff is
bad
and so maybe we need the existential
threat from the outside in order to
unify us internally what do you make of
that concept
yeah i mean i i think that there is a
lot to that i mean i think the united
states has always sort of
does better as a unified entity when we
think about our role in the world and
our kind of
mission in the world and you know
external threats can play that role
very effectively and it doesn't need to
be you know quote unquote existential
right like
i don't know there's not going to be
like chinese tanks rolling down fifth
avenue uh but there's a challenge to
american
primacy in the world that i think is
quite real and that when
the vast majority of americans look at
it they will find it disturbing
and it's not just that you see what we
have in common with each other but you
see that we have an interest in making
our institutions
work right i mean part of the essence of
this cultural war
politics is that you know people just
disagree about stuff
right and that's life and we live
different lifestyles and i know
people who you know my wife's from texas
so i know lots of people down there they
drive pickup trucks we have a prius here
in dc right
and that correlates really strongly with
your voting behavior
but it's not a political issue right
like
it should be allowed to buy a pickup
truck and it should be allowed to buy a
hybrid sedan and people should be
allowed to live in the countryside and
people should be allowed to live in the
city
and none of that's really controversial
right but you know opportunists
demagogues looking to get clicks looking
to get votes you can sort of pick at
these scabs of cultural division between
us
or you can look at a situation say okay
we've got serious problems right
and we need to actually try to address
them and focus on like what are choices
that we
need to make and what are questions
where we can really just say like
live and let live like it's a big
country and that's like
part of the genius of america right it's
just like literally a big place
with a lot of different stuff going on
and that's fine well
that does raise the question of what it
means to have the systems work so from a
conservative
or classical liberal perspective one of
the things that works about the american
system is that it's actually very hard
to get things done
right if you're sitting in my chair
you're very happy with the fact that
there are checks and balances that the
fact the fact that their subsidiarity
that most things that are done are are
supposed to be done at the local level
that it takes an awful lot of agreement
originally at least under the
constitutional structure in order for
everything to get done which is why you
have different constituencies in the
house and the senate and the presidency
is supposed to be checked by both the
judiciary and the executive
and the legislature and all of all of
the rest it seems like
a lot of the talk really since the
beginning of the 20th century has
censored on
how if we just make government more
unitary either through a bureaucracy
or through alleviating some of these
checks and balances you know there's
talk now about
reconstituting the senate adding
particular states to make for broader
majorities or getting rid of the
filibuster
how this gets things done and and that
may be
a very basic root question that you know
needs to be answered and
the reason i say that is because you've
kind of posited a couple different
visions of the country one is things we
need to get done together and one is
things where we need to leave each other
alone
and it seems to me that very often those
two things are very much in conflict and
if i have to opt for one of those things
especially in a broad diverse country
i'm going to opt for a government that
is
is not empowered to invade our ability
to leave each other
alone and that an attempt to impose from
above actually is going to exacerbate a
lot of the divisions we're feeling
i mean there's something to that i mean
you know what i was really thinking of
though is the
tendency right and like president trump
is a huge practitioner of this
although not by any means unique to just
sort of inject
cultural controversies into the
political sphere
right sometimes often without any real
policy content to it at all
but just to say that like okay now what
we all need to be doing is like yelling
about what these guys here
over here doing uh you know your point
about sort of veto points
in the u.s constitutional system is a
good one i was actually i was talking to
ezra klein good friend of mine i believe
a guest on your show
about some of you know his work on on
the senate and i was trying to say to
him
that you know i think libertarian minded
people classical liberal people
see the policy stability that that the
u.s
system provides as a sort of good in and
of itself right
so it's not neutral to say okay we
should have more
kind of get things done enos you know
one argument that i would
make on the contrary is that it's not
1790 anymore
so we have done a lot of stuff right and
so
one of the things that we now make it
hard to do is like repeal any old rules
or you know re-examine anything so it's
not
totally obvious to me which way this
does and doesn't kind of work
but the main point that i think is
most relevant today right is like what
level of decision
you make things on has an impact on
outcomes right so one thing that people
been arguing about
lately that again president trump has
brought up but that is featured in my
book and
you know is is important is like do we
make
housing policy decisions at this
incredibly local level uh which is what
we do right now right
it's super localized a lot of
neighborhood control
and that's a big reason that in places
like california places like new york to
an extent here in d.c
the regulation is so incredibly tight
right and we have incredible scarcities
there's huge affordability problems uh
where you live
in particular and so you know that's an
example where subsidiarity
leads to high levels of regulation right
whereas if you make the decisions at a
higher level
you get a lower level of sort of
regulation there and you have to make a
decision like what's
most important there right this kind of
vision of community control
or a vision of a more market-oriented
kind of society you know in that case
i think clearly we need higher level
decisions we need less regulation
we need more abundance of housing but
you know these different principles just
come together in a part in different
ways at different times
so in a second i want to get more into
your book one billion americans and ask
why a billion
where the number come from we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about life insurance
if you're a responsible human being like
you're an adult and you have a family
and people who depend on you
you need life insurance because god
forbid something should happen you want
to make sure your family
is taken care of now i know there's a
lot going on right now a lot of people
aren't even aware if
it's possible to buy life insurance at
all good news it is it's very easy to
shop for life insurance and if you have
loved ones depending on your income
you really need to get life insurance
right now how can you achieve this you
should go over to policygenius.com
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
policy genius it's an insurance
marketplace here's how it works step one
head on over to policygenius.com and in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top
insurers to find your best price step
two you apply for the lowest price
step three policy genius handles all the
paperwork and the red tape
policy genius works for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything for you
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam and do it all
over the phone which is really great
these days if you need life insurance
head on over to policygenius.com right
now to get started
you could say 1500 bucks or more a year
by comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice and very very important to
get it right
so one billion americans is about the
principle that we should have more
americans this is something that i
totally
agree with by the way on any number of
levels um but uh why one billion
um you want a super precise calculation
you know i went to the lab i
crunched the numbers um look so you know
obviously on some level it's a nice big
round number
also if america had the population
growth of canada
and we sustain it for the next 80 years
we'll be at a billion and 2 100. so
that's a kind of nice way to think about
it
it would also give us the population
density of france uh france is a country
a lot of people are familiar with
it's a it's kind of nice place you know
they've got some vineyards they've got a
nice coast
uh because you know what when i say this
right a lot of people's reaction is like
oh my god you know
it's gonna be like kowloon walled city
everywhere and i want people to
understand that the united states is
just a very
sparsely populated kind of place it used
to be even more sparsely populated right
when our
founding fathers you know were here in
this land
they were like we better get some more
people because they wanted the united
states to be a major
power in the world right they didn't
have our contemporary language of
international relations but
you know shining city on a hill and
abraham lincoln in his 1864 message to
congress you know he says
we should get some more immigrants here
it's going gonna be part of how we
rebuild after this this tragic civil war
um you know uh this is probably not the
ben shapiro show audience but you know
my progressive friends will want me to
acknowledge
that some bad things happened across the
settling of the west and all that kind
of stuff uh but you know it was done for
a reason
and i'm basically arguing for a
continuation
of that kind of vision that you know the
united states uh
is great and should want to be great and
powerful
and that that means having more people
so i'm perfectly willing to acknowledge
the uh the tremendous evils visited upon
native americans
uh by uh okay i mean just so we're we're
we're all in agreement
yeah no we we should all be i mean that
that's an easy one that's this seems
like a pretty easy one but it is also
important to mention that america was on
an average basis extraordinarily
sparsely populated at the time of
westward expansion
uh which is i mean that's just factually
true so when we talk about um
you know one billion americans one of
the things i was going to ask about is
population dynamics so
you put a lot of focus on for example
china and the chinese population
uh it's expected to peak in about 10
years and then it's expected to start to
decline pretty rapidly after that
because of their misbegotten one-child
policy
so they're going to end up with about
750 million people supposedly by the end
of the century
um and if you look at sort of the list
of countries with high populations
it goes india china the united states
pakistan
indonesia obviously there doesn't seem
to be a tremendous correlation between
a country's power and the size of its
population we're not supremely worried
about india overtaking the united states
and they have a larger population than
anybody else
we're not supremely worried about
pakistan or indonesia these days so so
why focus on the number of people living
in the country
well you know i mean aggregate gdp right
is like population
times per capita income uh it's not the
only thing in the world by any means
right i mean for a long time
china was just desperately poor so even
though it was a huge population
it was still not that important of a
country but we're now at a point you
know
china is still a fairly poor country
it's about on a par with like mexico
bulgaria depends how you measure it
but because the chinese population is so
large right they have now this
incredible
clout on the world stage and we were
talking about the nba there was this
great pen america report two weeks ago
about how
chinese sensors now dictate the content
of hollywood movies
because they've got the largest you know
domestic box office
uh you know there's also hard military
power in which the aggregates
you know really matter right you can get
it together build aircraft carriers
build
you know missiles that can attack our
ships these kind of things
so you know we can hope that china
stumbles
right they have some serious demographic
headwinds there you were talking about
the legacy of the one child policy
there's also questions as to how
sustainable the rapid economic growth
will be
it's totally possible that we'll just
kind of fall into some good luck
right and between the aging of their
workforce and some economic problems and
maybe they make some policy mistakes
here and there and america stays number
one anyway
but you know one of my premises in this
book is we control our own destiny much
more than we control
their destiny right and if we have ways
to grow our population that are
consistent with prosperity
obviously we don't want to shrink to
like pakistan living standards
and if that was the choice i don't think
we would make it uh but the argument of
the book is that by you know supporting
parents and children
and by being smarter but also more open
to immigration
we can sort of you know have our cake
and eat it too so i want to talk about a
variety of kind of tactics that you talk
about in terms of increasing the
population we'll get to immigration in a
minute because it's really fascinating
but
let's talk a little bit about some of
the measures that you discuss in terms
of making it easier to to raise kids
so when we look at sort of the
demographics in the united states and
who actually is having kids
it seems that there's very little
relation between
sort of the benefits that government
provides and the having of children what
i mean by that is that
a lot of the benefits that you advocate
for in terms of broadening and deepening
the social safety net have been
undertaken by
virtually all of europe europe all of it
has a lower birth rate than the united
states
uh the united states birth rate is
driven largely by immigrants and
religious people
right i'm religious my wife's religious
and so we have three kids
uh we plan on having more kids uh the
religious population of the united
states continues to have many many
children
and as the united states secularizes and
as it gets more prosperous uh there tend
to be fewer and fewer children born
so what why do you believe that that
broadening the social safety net or
adding sort of marginal benefits
uh or even maybe not so marginal
benefits to to people who are having
one or two children is going to lead
them to have more children i mean i i
just
as a person with a lot of kids it's
never occurred to me that i'm going to
have or not have a kid based on whether
the government provides me a slightly
increased
earned income tax credit well look i
mean
i think it's very clear that religiosity
is the sort of biggest variable here
right
that you know if you see like why do
americans have more children than
europeans it's because we're much more
religious
and that's clear if you look internally
to the united states but then when you
look
at europe right which is very secular
society
it's true that the more generous uh you
know nordic scandinavian countries
france
people have larger families there than
they do in spain italy
uh southern european countries that tend
to be stingier with their benefits
um you know i mostly rely for my sort of
math on this by the work of a guy named
lyman stone who's a religious person
himself a conservative person
you know when he argues that cash
benefits to parents when you look
internationally
makes a real difference to fertility and
to what it is people do
uh there's also an interplay between
these kind of things right so
one issue that you know conservative
people have paid more attention to
than progressive people is the way
aspects of the welfare state
create marriage penalties for
working-class people in particular
uh so because i'm a liberal person i
advocate getting rid of these penalties
by making the benefits more generous
it's also possible to eliminate the
penalties by making the benefits
stingier you know if you want to write
that book uh
more power to you my book says more
generous
but either way right if what you're
concerned about is family policy
it's the existence of the penalty which
is a problem
and there's an interplay right between
material factors and cultural factors
people who have children are more likely
to go to church people who get married
are more likely to have children right
these things kind of
come together in a sort of cycle i was
on tyler cohen's show and you know he
asked me like should we make people be
more religious
and i don't know i mean maybe
uh but it's like well what are you gonna
do right like it's a it's a free society
it's it's so i don't think we have that
lever to pull
exactly but i mean i definitely agree
that religiosity
is the number one relevant variable here
and not like stuff in the welfare state
so in a second i want to ask you about
some of the incentivizations and some of
the programs that you're
that you're talking about because it is
it's definitely interesting
stuff and it does kind of cross-cut some
political lines so we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
hiring and firing in this economy
ziprecruiter will help you
they send your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job sites but they don't
stop there but they're powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then actively
invites them
to apply to your job ziprecruiter makes
hiring efficient and effective with
features like screening questions to
filter candidates
and an all-in-one dashboard where you
can review and rate your candidates
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day whether you're
looking for a job or whether you're
looking for somebody to hire
ziprecruiter can help you i mean let's
be real about this
everybody's got employees they can
upgrade let's say for example you have
an employee like
let's call impovel and let's say that
his job is to make sure that the
teleprompter is working properly and
then just before the shoot the
teleprompter collapses in on itself like
a dying star you might think to yourself
hey i need to check out zip recruiter to
try ziprecruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
ben guest that is ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t because i have a guest
ziprecruiter.com
ben guest zipper crew is indeed the
smartest way to hire alrighty so
let's let's talk for a second about some
of these policies so one of the policies
that you recommend
uh is essentially free child care uh
this has been recommended by people
including ivanka trump the the kind of
increase in childcare
policies uh and there are a lot of quote
unquote common good conservatives who
who believe in this also or i mean i
think that for example tucker carlson
would probably advocate
uh for for something like this uh
elizabeth warren actually made a pretty
interesting argument against this back
when she was
in her more i think philosophically
interesting days when she was more
heterodox let's put it that way and
in the two income trap back which was at
harvard law school in which she
suggested that it actually provides a
certain disincentive
uh to people to have lots of kids to
provide free
health to provide free child care
because it actually incentivizes two
parents in the workforce two parents in
the workforce means
that moms cannot actually afford to stay
home and and if you're in the workforce
you tend to have fewer kids
so the idea there would be that you're
actually providing a sort of
incoherent penalty uh for people who are
who are staying home and taking care of
many children for example
yeah i mean this is i think an area
where i disagree with some of the
current
democratic thinking which is exclusively
focused
on putting people in center-based child
care right
i think that if you're going to have a
viable politics around this you need a
kind of
home care version you need a way for
stay-at-home parents
to access those benefits for themselves
the question of exactly how you want to
design a system like that is a little
bit
challenging uh but i agree i mean
more broadly even than the sort of
technical details right
i think because the people who craft
politics and policy for the democratic
party are almost by definition
like successful career-oriented people
you don't get to
like write policy ideas for elizabeth
warren uh without being
you know like really into your job it's
a hard job to get
and so they'll talk about it in those
terms right there was a democratic
debate
in which they talked about child care
affordability problems
and every single person who spoke about
it they spoke about the risk
that the expense of child care will
force mothers
out of the workforce um which is a real
thing that happens and it's a thing that
you know
bothers people but most americans
you know work to live right they don't
live to work they have
jobs they don't have careers and if you
want to do
family policy in a sensible way you need
to speak to those
people um you know and so there's a lot
of mommy war
content that you can access on the
internet if you want if you look at
polls you know
there's a large slice of women who say
they'd like to be home full time
they'd like to work full-time and then
the
median woman i guess you know says she'd
like to work part-time she'd like to
spend some time with their kids
it's a it's tough right this is one of
these things where like it's a big
country and
you can't make everybody happy all the
time but i think you know you should try
to design a system
that facilitates uh some optionality
there right that creates
child care centers that you know have
quality have some merit have some
economies of scale to them
but that also gives financial benefits
to people who are trying to spend time
at home with their own children
so when we talk about increasing the the
social safety net and various programs
designed to make life easier for people
who are having children
this also raises the issue of
immigration in a different way so
one of the things that that has been
fairly true about the the scandinavian
countries particularly
are these vast debates that have
happened over levels of immigration
where you've seen populist right-wing
parties actually winning increasingly
in the scandinavian countries that were
largely known for their social
progressivism
uh and largely on the basis of
immigration people saying you know we've
set up these broad social safety nets
and now we have a lot of people who are
coming in specifically to take advantage
of those social safety nets
and that's also creating some massive
cultural division because when you
have broad numbers of people coming from
cultures that are not
swedish culture for example then you end
up with enclaves that actually divide
the country
further so when it comes to immigration
you're an open immigration
person i tend to be libertarian on
immigration with a couple of exceptions
one i think there should be some real
rules about who gets to access the
social safety net
too i think that you should you know
have some general warmth toward basic
american principles like freedom of
speech i don't think that
uh you know we should be uh sort of in
let's put this away
i think that there there's people come
to the united states with sets of
pre-existing values and those values
don't always match the values
of the declaration of independence but
overall on an economic level i'm fine
with increased levels of immigration
particularly through the legal
immigration system
do you worry that increasing the social
safety net does have to come with
some of the countervailing concerns
about immigration that we've seen in
other countries
well i mean we have plenty of concerns
about immigration in our country
uh you know and and i mean i think yes i
mean like i think you need to try to
address these concerns right i mean my
biggest point about immigration in the
book
is that the value of immigrants and
immigration is really high
and it's in fact higher than most people
think uh but people have a lot of
concerns about immigration
and that's okay right we can't just yell
at them
and say like hey like stop being so
racist man like because i don't know you
know people
people think what they think and they
have their reasons to worry
uh but we should try to address those
concerns right so
something some republicans in congress
say is well we should have
a points-based system for immigration
instead of doing it on the basis of
family
so i say fine but then they say well and
we should cut the flow of legal
immigrants
in half so i say well maybe let's not do
that right like
if we could select immigrants better
right if we could be
say okay these are more skilled people
they're going to have a more positive
contribution to the tax
base then that's all the more reason to
have more immigrants but
also i think we should be open to
cultural concerns right
if we want to say uh look there's native
english speakers in the world right
whether that's from the bahamas or
canada or new zealand maybe it can be
easier for them to come because
like we care about english we like
english and i think we should
think about you know even sort of
favored
groups abroad right that you know
something that happened uh back when
obama was president and there was this
big to-do about syrian refugees
and you know a lot of republicans i
don't even remember why but they were
like well we don't want to have any
refugees from syria
and then some people were saying well
you know there's all these uh
christians actually in the middle east
and some of them were in the refugee
pool
and i think somebody said i think it was
ted cruz was like well maybe we could
have a special program for
syrian christians to come and everybody
just yelled
because it's discriminatory um so what
we wound up doing was
i mean it wasn't that we became more
generous to syrian muslims right we just
like had almost no people i don't think
it would be
crazy to say we have a sort of special
fondness for middle eastern christians
and want to bring them into the united
states that they are
you know minorities in their own sort of
cultural milieu there might have more
resonance in the united states
there's a lot of arab christians
historically have come to the united
states settled in michigan have done
very well here
uh if people i mean i'm not christian
myself neither are you
but that's the majority culture in this
country and
uh you know and i think something that
jewish people uh
like ourselves have gotten used to to
some extent is that like
america's like been been very good to
the jews uh
but it's also been a christian country
right it's like christmas is a day off
and passover isn't and it's a little
inconvenient to go
see your family but you know like you
make do right like all things considered
it's fine and so making some affordances
for that kind of cultural chauvinism in
the context of continuing to be open to
immigration
to me you know it makes a fair amount of
sense even if it's not
my personal preference like you got to
work with the public that exists
in a way that i think people are
sometimes too resistant to yeah speaking
of that i mean
one of the things you talk about in the
book and this is a really fascinating
part of the book because it really is
there's so many kind of wholesome
debates in the book uh the you you talk
about
uh the the attempt to repopulate kind of
dying areas of the country these old
steel towns that have fallen apart
and various incentive programs that can
be used to repopulate those areas i'm
going to talk about that
in just one second first let's talk
about how you're sending your mail these
days
as we slowly adjust to the new normal we
still need to be smart about how we do
business
luckily there's stamps.com they make
things a lot easier thousands of small
business owners have discovered the
benefits of stamps.com in recent months
they've been able to keep their
businesses running
avoid the crowds at the post office all
from their own computers
now some of us are smart and we've been
using stamps.com for years on end with
stamps.com
you can print posted john demand avoid
going to the post office stamps.com
offers ups services with discounts up to
no residential surcharges as well here
at dailywire as i've said we've been
using stamps.com since 2017. we don't
waste our time and we don't waste our
money stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need directly to your
computer in the comfort of your home or
office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices an online seller shipping out
products or you're just working from
home and you need your mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official u.s postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it and once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a pickup or drop it in a
mailbox it is that simple
like i said with stamps.com you get
amazing discounts five cents off every
stamp up to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates you're
going to save time
you're going to save money go to
stamps.com right now
go check them out right now for a
special deal my listeners get a special
offer
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale no long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro again that's stamps.com
enter shapiro at the top of the home
page for the special dealstamps.com
enter shapiro so let's talk for a second
about
the the attempts to revivify certain
parts of the country that seem to be
dying
so i i will freely admit that i am of
the kevin williamson
mindset which is if your town is dying
you should pick up and you should leave
uh i've been pretty clear about this
that uh one of the
great tragedies in my view in terms of
sort of the american mentality
is that it used to be considered you
know fairly rote that when you became an
adult
there'd probably be a lot of movement
americans are now traveling less than
they ever have in terms of
leaving home for a job travel is easier
than it's ever been or at least was
until covet
you could pick up and you could move
certainly just physically more easily
you can move to different areas of the
country there was more mobility and
until very recently there were a lot of
jobs in various sectors uh
that were available and yet we seem to
have kind of
inculcated in people this certain level
of
expectation that they should be able to
continue to live in the town where they
grew up and the jobs will simply
come to them uh you talk about some
programs for revivifying some of these
towns where the economic base
has left i wonder if you could talk a
little bit about those because
again i wonder whether we are making
allowances for badly governed towns as
opposed to actually
you know driving people toward governing
their towns better
well you know so so there's sort of two
things that i talk about one is the idea
of trying to
move some government agencies out of the
dc area
and possibly some some other kinds of
deconcentrate some other economic
sectors
technology in the bay area things like
that move them to places where
the cost of living is lower and there's
frankly more
desire to see jobs i mean one of the
most striking things was when
amazon did that like hq2 raffle and they
were like all right we're going to come
to new york and all these new yorkers
were like ah we don't want you
um and you know that's that's new york
for you to an extent
right like it's it's a really big city
like it's really crowded
um they i grew up in new york so so i i
know it well and and i love it but it's
like you know
new yorkers like they think they don't
need anybody um there's so many places
that would be thrilled to have a giant
amazon office like
manifest itself in the middle of their
downtown and to facilitate things like
that happening i think would be a useful
role for the federal government
the other is an idea that the u.s
conference of mayors
sort of endorse that's been in a couple
different presidential campaigns
and that's to sort of let localities
that want to
sponsor extra visas for immigrants who
you know could come and live in akron or
toledo or cleveland or i should probably
name some cities that aren't in ohio
uh but you know those are the ones that
are i've got ohio on the brain
um you know and and come because you
know you look at
say like i don't know buffalo right um
buffalo
it's just like it's really cold there
man and
people people all else being equal like
they don't like to live in cold places
uh and you know it had some original
rationales for being there related to
industry and i think the erie canal
and something to do with waterfalls i i
don't even know um
but you know it's fallen on hard times
uh but in the global
scheme of things like buffalo is an
amazing place to live like there are so
many places
that are so much worse than any american
you know mid-sized cold weather city
right and to let those places take
advantage of that kind of
asset by bringing more foreign-born
people over that can help stabilize the
economy and and create some opportunity
there
to me makes a lot of sense um so now you
mentioned the idea that like maybe
people
should just leave um that used to be me
i i if you go back you look at my slate
archives i was full of like
you know like f this town man like we we
just got to get people out of here
um i think it's proven to be a little
bit of a political dead end
right i mean i think uh donald trump one
of the things he did
that really resonated with people was to
speak to the desire to see
revival uh in their communities and from
a technical standpoint what i think is
correct about that is that the scope of
places that are losing population right
now
is too broad right it's something like a
third of our rural counties are losing
population
it's dozens and dozens of sort of small
cities across the
the northeast and also the midwest and
it can't be that like
each of those places is making bad
decisions
it's at the overall pace of growth in
the american population is just so low
that for any place to grow fast the way
you know like austin and nashville are
other places have to be losing and when
you're losing people
it creates real problems i mean i think
it's sad to see all that built
infrastructure kind of waste away
good cultural amenities wasting away and
you know we need to
try to do something to bring
opportunities to people where they are
now one of the things that you recommend
uh in the book that
a lot of what you've just said i
actually agree with and one of the
things you recommend that i also agree
with is the idea of putting universities
in some of these towns you've got a
state that's building a university
anyway why not put it in a place
where you can actually uplift the i mean
it's state project anyway that's fine
um but if you're talking about um one of
the things you talk about is the federal
government putting restrictions on the
ability of localities
to sort of offer goodies to various
companies to come in now i on an
ideological level object
to you know various towns offering
goodies i i don't like the idea of
subsidizing companies it seems like
crony
cronyism to me but one of the things
that is not
exactly a goodie is just localities
offering lower tax rates so one of the
reasons you're seeing this mass outflow
to nashville
and austin two cities that you've
mentioned is because there are zero
percent tax
rates in the states in which those
cities are located and you're seeing the
same thing in florida you're now seeing
a net outflow
from places like california to places
like nevada to places like arizona to
low-tax states
with an urban base of of people who can
who can work there
and i wonder if that's not a good thing
meaning that it
it seems like a lot of the places that
are that are losing population are
places that
are in fact over-taxing and
over-regulating and there's a natural
movement of business away from those
places to places that are
more conducive to doing business and why
is is that a bad thing
i mean i think it's actually probably
more regulatory thing that than a tax
thing uh you know it's not
bad exactly that there's some
competition you know so you look at
california
you live in california right and
unfortunately tax is there for
taxes there for um high-income people
are uh
quite high um and i i think this is a
successful show and
you know i know this i've noticed
technology people hollywood people are
are doing well and they're paying very
high taxes also there's a lot
of people leave california but it's not
actually
rich people who leave california it
tends to be working-class people
are leaving california and it's because
the the housing costs in california are
incredibly high um and you know i mean i
i've written it extreme length about
that i mean it's a regulatory issue it's
a huge crisis i think
by far the biggest failing of the sort
of progressive
you know coastal america is those kinds
of things and
that's fine right i mean it's um the
best thing
would be for you know new york and
california and new jersey connecticut
to get their act together um and you
know be more affordable places to live
but it's great i mean one of the
incredible strengths of the united
states compared to a country like the uk
or france
is that we have these multiple centers
right so
if new york and los angeles become
over-regulated
the way london and paris are like you
can go to houston
right we have lots of different big
cities and that kind of optionality
has been one of our big sort of
strengths here i think that's different
from
when cities get into these bidding wars
for each other where it's like
i'll give you you know whatever special
tax break to move your headquarters here
that actually one of the reasons to try
to clamp down on that sort of thing
is to encourage places to compete on the
fundamentals which is
you know either you have your taxes low
or else you're providing some kind of
service
in exchange for the taxes that's like
really good right i mean
in theory that's what they would say
they're doing in new york
is you know we have these awesome public
services and you know i do
challenge people sometimes like is that
how true is that right um you know
there's
there's elements where it is true and
there's there's unique amenities there
that people don't have elsewhere but
i that's exactly what's wrong with this
kind of like
let me throw you know a billion dollar
special property tax exemption at you
right to move in here is that places
should be competing on the basis of some
kind of value
i totally agree with this i mean they
should be competing on the basis of
broad value and
here's my prediction over the next
couple of years you're about to see high
income people leave
california in massive numbers and
spoiler alert by the time this broadcast
i am one of them and so is my entire
company but
you know by putting that putting that
aside um
the that's right a different sort of
broader question which is
uh the book relies on as you mentioned
aggregate gdp is sort of the measure of
the strength of the country there are
two ways to go about aggregate gdp
obviously one is to increase the
population
you and i actually agree on a lot of
those things i think that uh
our moral positions on abortion may be a
separator there but that's more of a
moral
issue on an individual level than it is
an argument like i'm not arguing
anti-abortion because i want population
growth i'm arguing anti-abortion for a
variety of other reasons
um but but the the um the other way to
obviously grow aggregate gdp is just
grow gdp period
meaning that the the great separator
historically speaking between the united
states
and say russia or between the united
states and china or it's in the united
states and india indonesia pakistan
has been a very robust free market
system and so
why focus if we're focused on
competitiveness with other nations
why focus on the production of children
and the incentivization of that as
opposed to focusing on
relief from regulation making this a
friendlier business climate
you know making it easier to start a
business in big states with heavy talent
bases like california or new york
i mean you can only you can only write
one book at a time um
i know the second one republican that's
sort of the problem yeah
so you know so so so the united states
is you know uh
we're a world leader in productivity
already uh which is great
um we should try to do better in that
regard one of the things though about
the challenge of china
is that the population there is so much
larger than ours
that they don't need to really match us
or even come
close to matching us in productivity in
order to sort of exceed us
in the aggregates uh when we were doing
the cold war with the soviet union
soviet population is a little bit larger
than the u.s population historically
but it's close right and so if the u.s
economic system
is in fact better than the soviet one
you know we win
whereas if communism is better you know
they're going to win right and so you
have this like famous standoff with
khrushchev
and you know the kitchen and we're gonna
bury you and
there was this moment i think when some
economists thought
capital accumulation in the ussr was
proceeding so rapidly that they really
would catch us
but they didn't right uh you know a lot
of other stuff happened in the cold war
but
fundamentally our system really was
better and
that sort of truth told out in the end
uh but
china's got three four times as many
people as we are we can't
count on the fact that our system is
superior to be good enough
to sort of give us that margin but of
course we should do what we can
to improve economic growth you know
domestically in the country
and a lot of the arguments of the book
are about things on housing about things
on immigration
that can help sort of facilitate that uh
but of course there's there's more to it
right i mean
uh like the healthcare sector is an
important topic for discussion
uh we could i'm sure you've done many
shows on them people write books about
it all the time
it's like doesn't even come up in my
book um there's plenty we could do to
sort of improve ourselves and that we
ought to focus on and
also plenty like we should argue about
right i mean one of my big themes is
like i want us to have joint projects i
want us to have
a sense of national purpose together of
course there's just always going to be
disagreements though about how you
should do things you know
abortion very important issue people a
lot of strong feelings about it
i think we disagree but i think this is
like a book that aims to have
ideas that can appeal to people who also
disagree about those other things
so in a second i want to ask you about
how we get to the kind of discussions
that you have in the book as opposed to
the discussions we're currently having
in politics which are vastly different
as i think we can both agree
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the earbuds
you're using to listen to shows like
this one
you need an excellent pair of premium
wireless earbuds
especially if you can get them at less
than half the price of the other guys
which is why i recommend wireless
earbuds from raycon
raycon's newest model the everyday e25s
those are the best ones yet six hours of
playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
more compact design and noise isolating
fit which is excellent if your kids are
screaming you while you're on the phone
this is a frequent occurrence in my home
raycon earbuds they are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires
no stems and you can give them a try
right now because they have a 45 day
free return policy so you can make sure
they are the pair of wireless earbuds
for you they look great they also fit
your ear perfectly unlike the other one
size fits all options you can actually
customize them so they fit your ear
really really comfortably and don't fall
out for a limited time
get 15 off your order at buy raycon dot
com slash ben that is b u i
r a y c o n dot com slash ben for a
special 15
discount on raycon wireless earbuds make
sure to check it out now while the deal
is still running
by raycon dot com slash ben once more
that is b
y r ay c one dot com slash ben you get
15 off your order and
it's not going to cost you an arm and a
leg like the other guys and if it's
better and it looks better go check them
out right now buy raycon
dot com slash ben so let's talk about
the fact that
you know we've been having a very nice
conversation here about all the various
policies and it's and honestly
it's fun i mean it's fun to talk about
various policies that we can try and
that we can
see whether they work and sort of the
underlying philosophical basis for this
this obviously doesn't happen very often
in american politics in fact most of
american politics seems to be
much more about imputing the intent of
the other guy for whatever policy
uh he is he is proposing so if if you
are
a democrat then republicans will suggest
that you're doing this because you're a
big government
authoritarian who wants to control
everybody else's life and if you're
republican democrats invariably suggest
you're doing whatever you're doing
because you're a racist
so how how do we get beyond
the the identity conversation and the
and the impugning of people's
motives uh and listen we all fall victim
to it sometimes and sometimes it's true
but how do we get to a broader
conversation uh about
uh you know the the policies uh and uh
and beyond the conversation about what
we suspect other people's motives are
you know it's hard but i always want to
remind people right politics
is a zero-sum conflict for power
right only one person can win the
presidential election
only one person can hold a given senate
seat policy
isn't like that right sometimes there
are areas where we just disagree
and it's irreconcilable but most of the
time people on the left people on the
right
care about slightly different things or
have slightly different priorities
and it's possible to come up with good
ideas that you know move the ball
forward
on both grounds and something that that
i reflect on sometimes you know because
i
i can be a feisty partisan person we
we've gone at it before and i i i like
to fight with people on the internet i'm
i'm not like going to try to say i'm
more high-minded than this uh but if you
look back in history
right at different you know like major
epics like
so little really turns on like who was
correct in some random house race in
1811 right like it's not that those
disputes
don't matter but we did advance
over time by having a better consensus
right like the overall ideas improved it
wasn't just that
one person or the other uh kind of won
out and it
makes me sad sometimes i i really like
uh hamilton you know as a lot of people
do it's great songs things like that but
getting people sometimes people start
looking at the past
like that and they apply just like
modern partisanship and want to argue
like jefferson or hamilton you know like
who would i vote for
in the 1804 election and like it doesn't
matter right like that's not an
intelligent way to think about the past
all those people um had a lot of ideas
that by today's standards we would think
are terrible
and they also had you know some
important insights and we just kind of
moved forward through a process of
gradual improvement
and it's just important to me to try to
make space for some conversations
that aren't just about the next election
right because
when we're talking about the next
election ultimately we've got to pick
right there's only one candidate
when we're talking about ideas like we
can talk about ideas we can disagree
about things we can agree about things
we can have interesting synthesis
we can learn from each other and to me
personally like that's more fun
right i look at you know what's selling
right now and i think like the top three
books on the bestseller list they're all
these like
books about why trump is bad um and i
agree i i think he is bad
i don't know how many books about that
you know liberals need to read for
themselves though like it's
a little boring i wanted to try to write
a book that you know i don't expect
anybody in america
is going to pick this up and say like i
am on board for 100 of this
but i do hope that everyone can learn
something from it just as you know we
can we can learn from
going on each other's podcasts so let's
talk about uh now that we've said that
we shouldn't talk about the election
let's talk about the election so
obviously right now as we record this uh
the heavy favorite
to win the presidency is joe biden uh
the only
real way that you could argue otherwise
if you're arguing that the polls are
system
systematically uh not taking into
account rural first-time voters
essentially in in some of the swing
states
uh which is is possible but unlikely i
mean it happened sort of in 2012 with
barack obama and first time black voters
in major urban areas
it could theoretically be happening this
time but again absence of evidence is is
not uh
is not an actual case that it's
happening at the time so
you know with with the race stacking up
the way it is let's say that joe biden
wins the presidency let's say that he
takes the senate along with him
how hard do you think a biden
administration pushes
for some of the policies they've been
talking about because there is this real
split between
and this always happens between how
democrats talk publicly for elections
and then how they talk sort of behind
the scenes like joe biden's presentation
to the american public during prime time
of the dnc was certainly not
the presentation that was being put
forth in sort of the discussion sessions
of the dnc earlier in the day
so what does it look like if uh if joe
biden is president and the democrats
take the senate do they kill the
filibuster
do they end up trying to add a couple of
states to the union
do they pack the courts like all these
things have been discussed what do you
think this actually looks like
yeah i mean you know i don't think that
stuff is gonna happen ultimately i mean
because to do anything right i mean you
saw this when trump
took over right not just him personally
you know republicans had the senate
majority but it was a narrow majority
and so there were lots of things that
quote unquote republicans wanted to do
that susan collins and lisa murkowski
didn't want to do
right and so the people who were going
to hold the the veto points
if democrats have a majority it's going
to be people like joe manchin and
kristen cinema
um you know maybe mark kelly some other
people who would have to win
and i just don't in my reporting
see an incredible amount of appetite
among those people
for big procedural changes
in part because they don't have a lot of
appetite for big substantive changes
and it's going to be frustrating to
people on the left who do want to see
that stuff
and it's possible like if bernie sanders
had won the nomination
and then he had faced the slings and
arrows it would have been a very
difficult general election campaign for
him
but then he won like i think a lot of
democrats would be
spooked in the way that republican
elected officials were spooked by trump
and they'd be saying oh my god like you
know my people aren't who i thought they
were exactly and i'd better go for it
but biden was clearly the most
conservative person in that field
he ultimately won the primary quite
handily
and i think it makes the more moderate
democrats in the congress
feel confident in their sort of their
own position and saying that they can
you know sort of flip the bird to people
on the left and
you know in some cases i i'm going to
find that disappointing i thought there
was a lot from that more ambitious
progressive agenda particularly on
healthcare
that i think is a good idea and where
biden is leaving
um leaving on the table frankly you know
useful necessary things
there's also a lot of areas where it's i
think probably for the best
uh that the left is not gonna be in the
in the driver's seat of policy after the
election
so do you think that there is going to
be unrest after the election and and if
so which side do you think it's going to
come from because
it's been very interesting i think there
have been a bunch of articles in the
last couple of weeks
for seeing you know widespread
right-wing violence in the streets
if joe biden should win narrowly or if
trump should win on election night and
then the mail in ballast come in and it
turns out that biden wins fairly broadly
uh which is quite possible considering
the level of mail and balloting that
we're going to see this time around
do you foresee that it seems to me
honestly like everybody is engaged in a
little bit of cosplay
uh the the the the amounts of actual
violence in the streets
the appetite for it is pretty low and it
seems like pretty small groups of people
statistically who are actually engaging
in it
yeah i tend to agree with that i mean i
think you know it's it's sort of fun
from the opposite right if i wrote an
article and i was like probably the
election will be peaceful
like i don't think a lot of people would
read that story
it's a little boring right and so it's
not just like well what gets what gets
the clicks there but it's like
you know the people most interested to
write articles speculating
about post-election violence are people
who in total good faith
like really believe in it uh but i i
think that stuff is
pretty overblown uh america is a
somewhat aging somewhat
complacent uh kind of place i mean it's
been you know
it's been disturbing to see some of the
things that have gone on in a couple
cities both in terms of
you know people rioting in the wake of
protests and then
like armed gunmen driving in from other
more conservative places to take charge
i mean i
i see why people are bothered by that
stuff but in historical context
it has actually not been that bad and is
also pretty detached from like actual
electoral politics
you know it's it's mostly being
perpetrated by people who are not like
engaged with the electoral system
so i don't really think the election
would be expected to
trigger big problems so as a person on
the left one of the big
kind of things that that's bothered me
about the the modern
left and i mean mostly the hard left and
i do make a distinction between sort of
the traditional democratic party in this
iteration
and a more radical version that you see
in for example the squad uh and
that is the focus on identity politics i
had this conversation obviously at
length with ezra klein because he writes
a lot in his book about his
definition of identity politics what do
you think of identity politics in the
democratic party
is it here to stay do you think that
that identity is is mainlined around
uh or pegged to ethnicity in inherent
characteristics
because it seems to me there should be a
pretty vast category difference made
between identity that you are able to
change
an identity that you're simply not able
to change like race or sexual
orientation or something
yeah i mean look i think identity has
always been an important part of
politics including ethnic identities in
the united states i mean i was reading
about
uh i forgot what it was you know is the
the army of the potomac in 1863
and lincoln has some particular general
in charge of the 11th corps
because most of the people most of the
soldiers serving in there
were german immigrants or
first-generation immigrants it was
important to have
this iconic german freedom fighter from
1848 in charge
even though he wasn't very good at
military command right see it's easy
for us to look back and be like you're
going to lose a war over identity
politics
man and like in the 1860s but also like
that's the nature of
politics and society and there's always
a
balance between you know making people
feel
incorporated by acknowledging their
identity and valuing it and going
too far so that you're creating
divisions uh rather than
than kind of healing them and you know i
i think
we go to war on like a second order
level over the idea of identity politics
at this point
uh while at the same time like people on
the right very much
practice forms of identity politics
right these sort of um
backlash to happy holidays uh you know
is
is a kind of christian identity politics
in the united states and
i find it a little bit uh deplorable or
i guess that's not the word to use um i
don't i don't love to see it
right because i feel like the happy
holidays right that's an effort to
acknowledge people like you and me who
are not celebrating christmas at the
same time i'll say merry christmas to
people
if it's going to bother them i think
identity politics i'm talking about is
more the kind of
you are you are pathologically incapable
of understanding people like me
right and you see that a lot in politics
right now is that you haven't
had this person's lived or shared this
person's lived experience therefore you
can't discuss this issue and that to me
is
the death of politics because literally
if you if you cannot at some point have
a conversation with somebody who hasn't
had your lived experience you'll never
be able to have a conversation with
another human being about politics none
of us have the same lived experience
yeah absolutely and you know you see
people taking this way too far
putting these like categoricals on and
they say look you've just
got to only listen to people who are
like this like you can't even weigh in
you can't have an opinion at the same
time you know earlier today there was an
interesting thing where
uh paul krugman said something like
there was no backlash against muslims
after 9 11.
and then lots and lots of muslim people
or south asian people who aren't muslim
but were mistaken for being muslim
they kind of like testified they were
like no this happened to me and that
happened to me and that happened to me
and you know that's valuable right i
mean it's not
helpful for like me and paul to sit
around as like
bearded secular jewish guys on the east
coast
saying that nobody said anything mean to
muslims like you have to listen to what
people are are saying about their lives
and
you know i have heard from
young from african-american men about
their experiences with the police
especially when they're young and that
makes an impact and you know
it it's important like the fact that tim
scott
is in the senate republican caucus makes
a difference on that issue because he
speaks to personal experiences that
other people in that caucus
don't have access to right so there's
real insight to the idea that diversity
of perspectives matters
that it's useful to listen to people and
to hear what they have to say about
their actual lives because we don't know
at the same time like i am a hundred
percent somebody
who stands firm on the view that like
objective statistical data
is really important and that we can't
like just listen
to people speaking their truth from
their heart because you know
people disagree right like you know
jewish people in america don't all have
the same
experience the same identities the same
black people latino people muslim
people so there's no way we're gonna
just like quote unquote listen
or use lived experience we have to look
to data we have to look to facts we have
to have arguments we have to
let everybody participate so you know i
i guess i have a wishy-washy view on
this so i want to ask
matt iglesias a few questions a few
final questions
starting with exactly how journalism
should be pursued since we both helped
found journalistic outlets
if you'd like to hear matt's answers you
have to be a daily wire member head on
over to dailywire.com click subscribe
you can hear the rest of our
conversation
over there well matt iglesias the book
is 1 billion americans be sure to check
it out math has been a blast thanks for
coming by
okay thank you
[Applause]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director
is pavel wydowski associate producer
nick sheehan our guests are booked by
caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
nika geneva
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday's special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020